i i think a lot of people want to know
this the answer to this next question
which is
what is the fastest road to financial
freedom you talk about everything you're
doing on youtube i have nothing to sell
i'm doing it to help people you've got
10 plus million dollars sitting in the
bank today oh way more than that talk
about that too like why
why i think everything's really fluffy
right now yeah so i mean i i sold three
companies last year and a house and two
cars so i sold everything last year
you're looking at what's happening
predicting there's inflated pricings i
mean a lot of people are really afraid
of inflation and i think that's super
warranted i think it's just like that's
a purely like
like looking at uncle warren right he's
got 150 billion in cash sitting right
now
he's not worried about it he's seen more
cycles than i have right so he's got 25
of his entire company value sitting in
cash
like he's waiting so a little
inflation's not going to kill me but
like when you look at the nasdaq during
the crash in whatever the year was um it
dropped by 78
right so
that would be significant it would be
significant i think just given the
timing i'm willing to wait a little bit
and see what's going on and i also am
very close to a transaction so i'm not
gonna like immediately allocate all the
money that sounds like a bad idea and so
that is why i have more cash than i
probably would normally so then back to
the quickest road to financial freedom i
mean the first answer that can't like
the bullet like the quick answer was
knowing thyself because right now
entrepreneurship's cool they won't be
cool in a few years when everyone loses
everything and so that'll probably
probably calibrate a little bit and so i
think it's just it's just skills are the
only thing that will always appreciate
in time and compound in concert so when
they work together if you know how to do
math then you can learn how to do
accounting if you learn how to do
accounting you can learn how to do tax
work you learn how to do tax work you
can figure how insurance works for your
insurance works then you all of a sudden
you're a cfo and you can prepare
companies for sale like the skills stack
on top of each other specialized skills
are valuable
independent of the currency or the
economic climate if you are good you
will always have a place to provide
value because people want good stuff
prices may vary currencies may vary but
people will want the things you have if
you are good
and the only way to get good is to work
and so i think that a lot of people
spend a lot of their time in paralysis
trying to figure out what the quote
ideal opportunity would be when you
won't know what the ideal opportunity is
because you don't have a baseline and i
believe that research is done through
doing
and you learn a lot more by doing stuff
in action and then you will gain the
insights of where the opportunities lie
which is why
y combinator comes up again what they
look for in past founders one of their
criteria for successful business is past
experience in the industry i just wrote
a tiny blurb about this in the book that
i'm writing that can be tangential like
if your dad owned a mechanic shop or was
a mechanic you probably know a lot more
about cars than you then like you to you
it seems obvious but like i don't know
anything about cars nothing nor do i
really have the interest but like if you
wanted to get in the space you probably
have some level of knowledge some people
look at just the whole world and they're
like
i don't know anything but this is maybe
a good like but i think it's better to
have some level because usually we have
learned stuff in our lives whether we
like it or not and starting in the in in
every industry that your parents your
cousins you worked in there was massive
opportunity it just depends on how you
structure it my first job was i was a
blender tender at smoothie king first
job i got blender tending not a very
good opportunity right i'm probably not
going to scale that
managing there probably not either
owning the the location a little bit
more leverage because now i've leveraged
on labor right owning the franchise
much more
all industries if you go high enough up
and this is the rule of thumb for anyone
if you want to see where where
opportunity exists look at the
businesses that have been here the
longest
because they make tons of money the only
reason they would exist is because they
can they can exist during downturns the
only way you can exist during downturn
is you make tons of profits all the time
so that you can weather it like jp
morgan's been here for longer than
anybody's been alive
right some of the big insurance
companies
why is insurance are profitable because
you pay them for nothing right
like you pay thousands and thousands
thousands a year for something that may
never happen and they just know how to
appropriately value risk
assess risk excuse me and so wonderful
business right insurance um and so the
the point is is like i've now learned to
see this is like when i see big
businesses the bigger the business the
more i realized that there's probably a
very high gross margin opportunity so
you look at the biggest companies on the
stock market look at what they're doing
the base unit that they're selling
typically has tremendous like the
biggest company in the world right now
in terms of profit is like exxon
that's number one in terms of net free
cash flow that's created and they're
crazy like people are like facebook no
it's it's excellent why because they
drill water out of the ground and they
sell it for however many hundred dollars
per
right it's not water it's oil but it
works the same way right and so and
that's a massive over generalization but
like you get the idea and so facebook
sells eyeballs which costs them
basically nothing google sells eyeballs
that cost them basically nothing you
sell for what the market values at
period and your goal as a business is to
drive your costs down as much as you can
as long as you're still long-term greedy
which is if you drive them too low or
you don't pay people well enough you
introduce new levels of risk which then
long-term you actually lose money so
that's when you get into the long-term
short-term like ceo ship of publicly
traded companies and stuff which we
don't need into but like if you if you
were to only own the company and you
could not ever exit and you made your
decisions with long-term greed in mind
um then you usually make the right calls
and i'll say one last thing about the
how to how to get freedom biggest
mistake that i see young people or
people who are young in the game making
is that they want to become millionaires
in 90 days when most times
you could guarantee that you could
become a millionaire in a decade but you
have to be willing to not be a
millionaire
for nine of those 10 years
and if i had everyone signed a contract
that said that when they were 20 they
could all be millionaires when they're
30. but no one's willing to do that and
so what happens is for the rest of their
lives they keep chasing the shiny object
over and over again and keep battling
the same boss and losing i mean there's
the investment side and i'm not i'm not
despite having a high net worth i'm not
an uber investor i've made my money with
businesses i haven't made my money
investing um and so for people who are
starting out
the know thyself pieces am i going to be
somebody who has entrepreneurial
tendencies and could potentially own a
business business ownership is the best
way
to create wealth it's also the best way
to lose wealth
it's high risk it's high reward it is
the way to the most wealth it may not
necessarily be the way to the fastest
wealth most guys who have
entrepreneurial tendencies could could
make 200 000 a year 300 000 a year
becoming excellent at sales
like if you just learn that skill and
that skill translates to all aspects of
life most people who are in business
know how to sell at some level they know
how to sell investors they know how to
sell their teams they know how to sell
someone to recruit to bring on like you
have to sell i think for most people
gaining that i think i think those
initial jobs are undervalued for your
ability to learn and so a lot of guys
are just looking for the perfect job
when the perfect job is the assembly of
maybe three or four jobs that you have
to to gain skill sets in different areas
and i think warren buffett said it best
that's probably a good wrap up which is
whenever you're working you should
either be learning or earning so either
you're working for the paycheck because
it's material to you or you're working
because the the incremental increase in
knowledge is material to you but it
should check one of those two boxes